that's actually something that my father
told me before i went to college
he was just like you know you should you
should write the book
and then once the book is published you
know you should write the screenplay
how many books have you written
i've written four books
um
the three that uh that i brought
with me today and a fourth one which is
a much smaller much smaller story it's
called uh kisses furtadi um it's like a
family drama you know young woman who
uh just lives under the thumb of her
older domineering sister and she ends up
meeting
a guy and and she
hopes that you know this you know this
guy
can be the beginning of something you
know a relationship or something that
can just kind of get her out of
this rut that she's in you know kind of
free her
almost
so it's a very small story very short
story um
gosh i don't even i don't even think
it's like a hundred pages
but um
that's the that's the fourth book it's
also my my most
polarizing
people either love it or hate it
because
because of the ending
uh okay yeah okay is it sort of a
was it whatever happened to baby jane
what
has anyone approached you on wanting to
turn one of these books into a film
no
no one has
but
i mean i have heard
some people describe a couple of them as
cinematic
but for me that makes sense considering
that a couple of them were
uh began life as screenplays that i
adapted you know into into novel form
but no one no one has approached me as
of yet but we shall see i always like to
tell managers when i talk to them that i
do come with ip i've got it so if you're
looking to adapt something i've got some
projects for you
we've been hearing a lot lately that
aspiring screenwriters should possibly
write a book before they write a
screenplay
what are your thoughts on that
i mean i think that's a good idea
um
that's actually something that my father
told me before i went to college
he was just like you know you should you
should write the book
and then once the book is published you
know you should write the screenplay
and i resisted that i don't i don't know
why i don't know why i felt that
writing the screenplay
you know instead of writing the book
first and then adapting it i don't know
why i felt that that was like
more authentic or pure but that's where
my head was at then
but now i would absolutely say yeah sure
write the book
uh write the book
if it does well that's great
uh
get some name recognition
you know writing and publishing a book
it certainly establishes you as a writer
i mean that's something that you can
carry with you you know um
people are certainly just like you
they're still asking you know when's the
next book coming out
you know even though i've
said time and time again you know i'm
actually focusing on screenwriting right
now the next book who knows
but um i think it's definitely a good
move you know i look at
nowadays authors are doing that authors
are writing the novels and then they are
adapting the novels you know as opposed
to you know another writer like i looked
at someone like jillian flynn
she did that you know with gone girl
and now she's actually
writing you know screenplays not yeah
adaptations you know but you know her
own
so i think that that's great so yeah
it's it's definitely a good a good move
do you think novel writing is easier
than screenplays because of the format
no
no
uh it's just different
it's just a different discipline you
know writing itself is difficult
um
coming up with the story and and and the
characters developing the characters and
everything it's all hard work
um
and i i really don't think that one is
easier than the other
you know
um
perhaps screenwriting might take a
little less time simply because
the format is the format you know you
know what you have to create
and you have you know these parameters
you know
please don't try to go above 110 pages
or 120 pages what have you uh whereas
with the novel you can expound and you
can embellish and you can write as much
as you want
um
but they're they're just different
disciplines i don't yeah i don't think
one is more difficult than the other
jay you just mentioned ip you come with
ip and you can tell that to a manager or
agent
how important is that for a screenwriter
well and when i said it i kind of said
it jokingly but also you know a little
serious uh but i i do think that it's
helpful
you know we're living in an era
where everyone wants to turn everything
into a franchise
which
i mean i guess can be cool
but
i feel that if you come to a manager or
a producer or someone
and you say that i've got something
that's already established right it's
already in a way been vetted it's got a
fan base of some sort
uh that may make it
a bit easier for you
you know you've come with something that
has a track record of success
it's like okay you know this this book
you know has sold relatively well or you
know this comic book is critically
acclaimed you created that oh okay so i
think that that can help
uh a writer in a lot of respects
so
if you've
got the ip if you've got whatever it is
you know whether it's a book comic book
if you're
coming with i don't know the stage play
or
or maybe if you've created like a small
line of toys that you can craft a story
around anything like that yeah i
certainly think that that helps
have you thought about crafting an
original trilogy to any of your works
whether screenplay
novels all right
i haven't
and it's it's because i'm i'm really not
a big fan of
sequels uh there are exceptions to
everything of course
uh
like i
love the marvel movies i love the marvel
cinematic universe i love that kind of
serial storytelling because it reminds
me of the comic books i was into the
comic books but
i don't think that everything
necessarily needs a sequel or or needs
to be you know
created uh
turned into a trilogy
having said that
because of
you know the popularity of franchises
series things of that nature
i have been toying with the idea
of
maybe
writing a sequel to
orange mound my novel orange mound
i do have a little idea rattling around
in my head
for a sequel idea
and
if i decide to work on it and
it comes out well
then perhaps i might
create a third that's the one kind of
property
so to speak that i have that i've
created that i've given a little thought
thought to about like
turning into a trilogy or whatever
is that because there are so many
characters involved
this is like a neighborhood of people um
no because actually you know like orange
mound is a small story it's got a small
cast of characters
um
[Music]
it's it's set in the neighborhood but it
doesn't it's not about the neighborhood
if that makes sense um but i do see that
as kind of a hook because we explored
different places that would be familiar
to people you know who were in memphis
um
but yeah it's it's not it's it would
just be you know
another story in kind of like a
familiar neighborhood
but not because of number of characters
or anything no
jay let's emphasize the fact that you
said previously that you don't like
sequels maybe even hate sequels
but let's say i'm a producer and i come
to you and i say i want to make a
trilogy
of your novel orange mound
which is sort of loosely based on
memphis or nashville memphis memphis i'm
sorry okay
and and this beauty shop and there's
different nefarious characters in there
and some good some bad
and i i'd like to take that property and
turn it into a trilogy
trust me
[Laughter]
of course you know i trust you um
we can certainly have that talk
uh i
look i want i want to make movies i want
to tell stories
and
whereas i don't believe that every story
needs a sequel
sure you know it we can we can do this i
mean
i'm in it for the art but i'm also in it
for
the commerce i like i want to make some
money and you know i understand that
this is a business show business
you know and uh if if sequels are
put on the table and said hey you know
let's let's discuss this i can at least
have the discussion
and um if i feel that there is a story
that
can be told with you know these
characters that
deserves to be expanded uh you know into
into
future installments
then sure why not
you know i
the reason why i have this disdain for
sequels is because i feel that
a lot of stories
are told like they're
they're these contained
uh entities right you tell the story and
and it's done
most stories are not crafted to be
sequalized
uh
and so with the sequel you're you're
almost trying to force it
and and that's where the problem comes
in for me
there's a sequel that came out this year
and i i
not gonna name it
it wasn't
bad
um i actually had fun with it
but for me it ruined the legacy of the
original because that story was told so
beautifully and it's such a classic
story such a classic film
that a sequel is unnecessary
and i don't think that the sequel added
anything and
you know people to this day are still
talking about the original
i feel like the sequel came and went and
i don't you know i don't it doesn't feel
like it has the lasting power
uh of the original
so it's better sometimes to just let
great work stand on its own don't try to
belabor it and then it ends up ruining
absolutely yeah absolutely